[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce ruban rose est ridicule mais je ne
peux pas l'enlever pour deux raisons je
n'arrive pas dé faire un noeud avec mes
pattes et ce sont les petites qui m'ont
ainsi enjolivé du moins le croit et je
ne voudrais pas leur faire de peine tout
a commencé il ya à voir avec la visite
de la jeune flora cousine de delphine et
de marinette vous allez voir votre
cousine fleurât elle est plus grande que
vous mais je voudrais dire vous prenez
exemple sur elle elles viennent passer
son certificat d'études et ses parents
sont fiers d'elle il voulait pas dire de
nous mais bon je ne vois pas pourquoi je
le serai pour être qu'un de ses enfants
il suffit d'avoir des enfants
[Musique]
bonjour ma nièce voyons ma tante motion
marine elle mesure delphine te blatty
fait je suis habillé comme il convient à
mon âge à la situation de ta part faites
attention vous allez vous décoiffer
puis je m'assois en attente j'ai des
souliers à la dernière mode des signes
de son passé pour la compagnie il
vendait alors on dirait des décharges
tout le monde ne peut pas vivre aux
sabots et à rome on dirait que le seco
c'est de l'organdi mais j'en ai d'autres
une rose avec une ceinture d'arrêt et
une verte avec un bilan de crêpes sur
l'épaule pourquoi tu des gonds tu as les
mains sol je ne sors jamais sans goren
si j'ai les mains propres
je trouve bien changé flore heures je
retire ce que j'ai dit c'était trop tard
les mauvaises idées satrape plus vite
que les puces trois jours après la
visite de leurs cousines flora
[Musique]
le sabot sais pas si commode comprend on
se fait surtout mal aux pieds ce qui
arrive aussi c'est que l'on entre par
dessus tandis qu'avec des souliers ya
moins de risques surtout si le talon est
un peu haut
les souliers c'est tout de même plus
joli c'est comme l'europe au lieu de
rester toute la semaine avec une robe
d'organes pour me sortir de leur moral
que souvent nous rendîmes c'est comme
les cheveux
au lieu de les avoir sur les oreilles ça
serait plus commode de les relever
et plus je lis au pays voilà des façons
de parler qui ne nous plaisent pas notre
père a raison est ce que vous avez perdu
la tête
vous pensez qu'on va nous laisser vos
souliers vos bonnes robe pour tous les
jours est ce que je trouve le plus fort
ce sont les cheveux relevés à votre âge
si j'en entend encore parler
aussi les petites n'en parlait plus du
moins devant leurs parents mais dès
qu'elle était seule j'ai mis des billes
aux normes est d'abord exigé dalo bref
une vraie frénésie de beauté s'empara
des deux petites et ne tarda pas à se
répandre dans la ferme
je ne voudrais pas te faire de pelle
mais tu as quand même un drôle de coup
droit drôle de coup bon mais parce qu'il
est trop l'on regarde le mien toi tu as
le coup au cou trop court
je dirais même que c'est loin d'être
solide et bien ce n'est pas la peine de
discuter mais sans parler du coup je
suis mieux que toi tu n'es plus meubler
les plumes noires des plumes jaunes et
surtout gf très beau panache tandis qu
toi alors je trouve que tu finis de
relancer beau te regarde et je ne vois
quand quitte à me plumer mûri faits qui
ne sont guère plus les autres c'est
comme cette crête rouge que tu as sur la
tête tu n'imagines pas pour quelqu'un
doc délicat combien cet écueil e dieye à
bessines je suis plus beau quoique la
tâche clubic toi vous avez fini de nous
disputer
je sais qui est le plus beau de toute la
sphère mari qui est ce ce matin les
parents sont venus me voir ils m'ont
bien examiner palper sous toutes les
coutures et ont finalement déclarés ou
ce cochon est magnifique on veut bien te
croire mais quand un homme dit qu'un
cochon est magnifique cela veut jules
avril évasif laissez moi rire et howie
le scénographe question de savoir qui
est le plus beau de vous trois leur
fougue avec sa pop trop étendue le coq
avec cette espèce de moignons sur la
tête
et quelle grâce aisée dans le maintien
de notre benoît et quelle dignité
croyez-moi il vaudrait mieux quand on
décide loin de la perfection ne croit
trop parler de bontin si j'ai un
comprends bien vous pensez être le plus
beau personnellement je ne pense
survient un je vous fais juge simplement
en effet j'en reconnais les jolies
petites plus ne marchait pas je suis une
bête de luxe je n'ai pas l'habitude de
me frotter à n'importe qui on va vous
demande par an mais nombreux c'est moi
qui m'excuse de vous dire les choses
aussi simplement
voyez-vous quand on veut être beau comme
je suis il faut en prendre la peine
c'est presque aussi difficile de le
rester ken de le devenir
et comment est ce que vous n'avez pas
toujours été bonne on quand je suis venu
au monde
je n'avais qu'un maigre duvet sur la
peau et rien qui permet d'espérer qu'il
en serait un jour autrement
ce n'est que plus un peu que je suis
devenu comme je suis
il m'a fallu les soins je ne pouvais
rien faire sans que ma mère ne
reprennent aussitôt ne mange pas de vers
de terre ça empêche la lune de pousser
ne sauve pas que le pied tu auras la
traîne de travers ne mange pas trop ne
voit pas pendant les repas et même
maintenant je suis encore au régime
quel régime le matin au réveil un pépin
de pomme reinette une gorgée d'eau
claire dit ensuite absolument rien aux
draps pépins de pomme reinette une
gorgée d'eau claire
la recette se répandit comme une traînée
de poudre
seuls les parents ne surent pas mis dans
le secret on pense à k leur âge ils ne
pouvaient plus embellir
mais depuis les souris jusqu'aux deux
petites chacun fut persuadé qu'il
suffisait pour être aussi beau que le
pan de se nourrir d'eau claire et de
pépins de pomme
[Musique]
vous venez de servir notre fourrage et
comme d'habitude je prends la fun
donnez nous plus tôt on ne paie pas
l'impôt - net et une gorgée d'eau claire
nous aussi mais là ils veulent pas types
de thons paix remporté l'un vite ce
qu'il me faut c'est un pépin de pomme
reinette avec une gorgée d'eau claire
aussi
mais pourquoi parce que je veux être
beau mon dieu que son il est bien
naturel que tu penses à être beau mais
pourquoi justement ne pas faire ce qu'il
faut pour le rester est-ce que tu ne
comprends pas qu'être beau c'est d'abord
être à un autre
oui ou non voulez vous me donnez un
pépin de pomme reinette et une gorgée
d'eau claire laisse-nous réfléchir mais
ce n'est pas tout faudra aussi m'emmener
promener tous les matins il faudra me
faire faire du sport et surveiller ma
nourriture mon sommeil mes
fréquentations ma façon de marcher
enfin tout entendu plan qui aura encore
pris une dizaine de kilos nous
commencerons en attendant tu vas manger
ta pâte et
[Musique]
vous partez déjà pour l'école oui mais
vous n'avez pas déjeuner enfin nous
avons du tram en jalles hier soir non le
produit bien voilà qui est singulier
enfin les bêtes de l'écurie ne
s'accommodait repas longtemps du régime
recommandé par le paon dès le troisième
jour le cheval qu'on allait atteler à la
voiture et les boeufs qu'on allait
mettre à la charrue se sentir les pattes
coupées bas c'est qu'en effet un pépin
de pomme dans l'estomac d'un cheval ou
d'un boeuf c'est à peu près comme rien
il y eut plus de constance chez les
animaux de basse cour
il faut dire qu'il n'avait rien à faire
qu'à bavarder c'est épouvantable ce
matin par erreur j'ai failli avaler un
grain de blé
moi je me promène le regarde en l'air
pour ne pas être tenté
moi je me sens des mises au jour un jour
quand je pense à ce que je mangeais le
goût je monte au front autres aoun ziab
elisson nous n'aurons bientôt plus notre
place dans cette base cours de campagne
nous devrions aller à paris il doit y
avoir à paris des basses-cours digne de
nous et ont opéré aux courses dans les
théâtres et dans les restaurants dans
les restaurants ça c'est sûr que veux tu
dire je dis que nous sommes des
imbéciles
dis plutôt que tu as faim parfaitement
mais il n'y a pas de honte
quant à la beauté par lawrence ho si
vous voyez vos plumes fatigué et a
beaucoup décharné vosges à bord aplati
je vais manger qui tient à la vie me
suis moi je ne céderai pas en effet le
coq demeura ferme partisan du régime
pépin tout au moins jusqu'au moment où
[Musique]
il manque le soleil se lève à ce que tu
attends pour chanter j'y vais je ne sais
pas ce que j'ai ce matin au haut du mont
dieu
il s'est évanoui rolala qu'est-ce qui se
passe
le réveil n'a pas sonné le coq s'est
évanoui
il n'a plus aucun ressort je pas entendu
le coq il s'évanouit
ça m'étonne pas il devenu aussi maigre
qu'un code de clocher il va falloir
saigner pour qu'ils sont encore bons à
manger sit-in on recommence pourra
manger c'est toi qui sera mangé
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que passer quinze jours le
cochon resta seul de tous les animaux à
suivre le régime dans toute la journée
ils mangeaient à peine de quoi nourrir
un poulet en bas âge
ce qui ne l'empêchait pas de faire de
longues promenades à pied de la
gymnastique et du sport en toute manière
alors comment trouvez vous opium
aigremont pour cochons tape au fait des
plis des ridge et des poches que j'en ai
une pige à non tant mieux mais je n'ai
pas fini de vous étonner
à propos faites moi donc le plaisir de
regarder au dessus de ma tête
vous avez vu quoi d'eau est quelque
chose qui pousse commune l'upp
mais non je dis rien du tout rend aucun
sens c'est drôle emma traîne la
voyez-vous après reims 1-2
tu parlais de ta queue elle est plus que
jamais en forme de tire bouchon en tiens
tiens ça c'est drôle ça peut-être que je
ne fais pas assez de sport ou ce que je
mange encore trop bref ce pauvre cochon
faisait de la peine à tout le monde et à
moi plus qu'à quiconque car je suis
extrêmement sensible aussi un jour j'ai
eu pitié de lui
[Musique]
est ce que tu vois pouces emmaüs
en effet il me semble bien apercevoir
quelque chose ce n'est bien sûr qu'un
début mais on dirait une promesse du
prochain la voilà qui pousse je suis
bien heureux emma prennent la voiture
aussi ta traîne
mon dieu je dois dire ne la voit pas bah
la vérité ce n'est pas encore une traîne
mais c'est déjà un très joli ballet qui
n'a pas fini de pousser bien sûr il faut
qu'elle grandisse encore oui oui mais
elle ne grandira que si tu manges
beaucoup et pour la hulpe c'est la même
chose
le régime dukan c'était excellent pour
tout mettre en train mais maintenant que
la hulpe et la traîne sont sortis il
s'agit de les alimenter ce fonds en vrai
je n'y avais pas pensé
je vais manger je vais manger j'ai une
huppe j'ai une traîne j'ai une traîne
j'ai une idée complètement génie puis
j'ai une très nombreux cochon il perd
complètement la tête à tête mais là et
re re il a tort d'être heureux puisqu'il
est fou vous me être fou et ouais tiens
fait leur âge
tu devrais rentrer voilà l'orage au
contraire je vais aller me promener sous
la pluie cela doit faire pousser les
huppés les traits je sens que c'est ma
ulémas traîne je ne le regarderai que
lorsque nous aurons fini de pousser
c'est ma hutte qui attire le tonnerre
cela prouve que j'ai une jupe voilà
l'orage qui se calme je vais montrer
mahut et emma traîne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la vache est finie
j'étais d'avoir un arc en ciel ah oui
regardera
moi
kibo oui il est beau on vous voyez je
fais la roue je suis encore plus beau
que je le pensais qu'est-ce qui se passe
quelque cent qui s'imaginent l'attentât
sous cochon c'est l'heure de manger
vous voyez bien que je ne peux pas ma
roue est trop large pour que je puisse
rentrer tu n'as qu'à refermer des plumes
84 à fatima
non c'est vrai je n'y aurais pas pensé
vous comprenez le manque d'habitude
[Musique]
c'était les couleurs de l'imagination
qui sont comme chacun sait les plus
belles du monde